dude me and obby and some friends went
to this like Soho House of Austin oh
right you were an austere oh man it was
fun was it oh this place do you know so
house here yeah yeah it's all pretend
just like the worst thing of Hollywood
yes there it's like a private club with
their food and they have great whiskey's
and hookah I was smoking whoo God Wow
I'd like to go there man
I [ __ ] live in sniped a little
ketamine
Brendon you can't do Special K jack is
that what it is yeah
ketamine that's a horse tranquilizer did
you do ketamine
you can't offend these things on my
podcast what's wrong with it
you're a drug it is ketamine it's a
trick course tranquilizer look up
ketamine there pass it around like is
[ __ ] for real vicks vapor spray dude
like look at everybody's ear all
ketamine you want to look at the wiki
yeah let me read it what I need to know
about it that medication mainly is
starting and maintaining a seizure
trance-like state well yeah and relieve
sedation ah my foot didn't hurt at all
other uses include for chronic pain
sedation or intensive K and their care
and depression I want to hug everybody
okay well I got real lovey-dovey on this
you snort it you are surpassing now what
is it
it's special K went love the cereal let
me try that thank you you are you like
your drugs dude I'm getting there I'm
living though you're very successful I'm
living wrong do drugs you're a bad
influence dude bloody or cloudy P that's
good for you and have that trouble
peeing or definitely so much halo our
blush lips blonde okay lips good inquiry
should ingest man I guess if you do a
lot lower vision yeah a little bit
shortness of breath
confusion convulsions good problems with
swallowing the solution fast slow
irregular heartbeat HS hives you're too
big to be doing this [ __ ] it says it is
if you're doing all the time at one time
use a nice steak salad I think I'll just
say I would not have done Special K C we
see that's a problem we just call it
Special K that sounds a little risky
yeah - call it ketamine yeah can I mean
does sound like a protein sounds like a
protein powder how's it gonna aminoacyl
rhymes with creatine yes and then also I
take kratom so Kratos still take kratom
do I have your organic dude I didn't
know any of this dammit you're one of
those guys that is very effective and
still you just grind it's fine ones like
Rogan who smokes weed and these more
intense than ever it's not like weed
mellow Joe out it's just he built an
empire ketamine is a medication side
effects include confusion no I didn't
have any of that this is so great well I
didn't know I did a real drug I had no
clue yes - that's omar you know we're
passing it on no you thought it was like
some cool there's hookah you got I was
like oh my nose is stuffy I'll try that
you did you did the gage rug - you know
special case the gay drug y know gage
drugs Molly no sir it's also special k
is done in the gay community why cuz it
relaxes you and it relaxes your boot
your body your booty all well yeah your
as well you're a lot more receptive you
know how you start but you know you
start fishes usually hall i love i was
pretty relaxed yeah and you know your
starfish is usually all ten-hut and
tight and all anal oh well your starfish
stops being so it's happy hour panel
it's happy a case in gay relax
it gets so you got you got a happy hour
all of a sudden your rumpy-pumpy feels
like it's happy hour all the time
because usually happy hours just like a
couple hours after work right now it's
happy hour all night long and yeah how
many times have i told you dude that
you're the bottom every single time and
a guy like me i might be skinny I made
it rawhide and cable got a dick on you I
got a dick on me and I'm older and I'm
dominant and you're trying to pour into
the South Dom and then oh yeah and we've
been friends
long time but you're all sniff he
sniffed up with the Academy didn't know
it laughs relax was some whiskey and
we're in the bathroom and often you hear
and you're like what you do and I go I
drew the bolt
I drew the bolt you and me and I'm like
hey I love you and you go huh I love you
tall dude on ketamine I would have said
I love and I go is that what's that spot
on the wall and you're like what spot
I'm like yeah you were peeing already
since mr. Han you know that no-good cat
space no it'd be like my face looks like
she's she looks like she smells
something bad cuz she bout to in so much
you know what in so mine and I'm like
keep keep keep your eyes on that spot
dude it have to be like mr. hands you
got it you better your move fast
yeah cuz you're gonna be like I didn't I
say I started this I saying
we're starting on Monday with our hair
did you yeah so you hear me go and you
go dude I mower baffle that ketamine as
a serious drug yeah dude it's the gay
drug I see I think that's in your circle
I don't think so that's okay cocaine it
sir Special K is cocaine flushes you out
so that you're clean pie at gay at gay
raves engaging in these ketamine this
well no it's a well-known yeah it's it's
it's well-known a lot of gay men are
very familiar with Special K a lot of
the a lot of these the party boys I
should say
I'm sorry you call it gay drug I'm just
saying that it's it's not there's a
reason it's used in in the gay sir I did
feel very relaxed and will give you that
yeah
now um do you feel you can get an
erection on it yeah see I think about it
opens things up in the back flop get
sloppy yeah you stop people open floppy
in the black no it's the our the way
yeah Lou sloppy in the front Blues in
the back not be in the brown and open
in the back hey hubby in the front and
open in the back special K is your best
friend yeah the shop is closed in front
but we'll take deliveries through the
back yeah that's right
sorry we're we're closing the front but
there's a secret secret entrance in the
back password your drug and the password
is awesome hmmm is the sphincter yeah
days I would've said if they said the
most popular gay drug is poppers what's
the one operator this right here alcohol
night charts that are inhaled and it
relaxes the sphincter muscles isn't that
special k2 no don't you don't lump all
that in [ __ ] find out what pop what's in
poppers I'm gonna tell you right now
what's up popper there's a Wikipedia
right there when you click on poppers
jizz we were looking at it not poppers
really yeah it's a slang term
broadleaves the chemical class called
alkaline nitrates that are inhaled
practical purposes Chris blood for them
increases higher rush sexual encounters
I ain't touching that
hold on poppers were private club
culture in the disco era but isn't what
I want to know special Special K for gay
parties hold on you can type anything I
know I sperm at a party you know look at
let me see what's in let me see what's
in the bottle k ketamine yeah anyone
else ever done it
no you higher chin has never cared I
mean I know people that did do it things
that they love it I don't know their
fate there are two girls and they both
said that they were just like really
gone gone yeah like they're out of like
gone with another dude no they were with
each other yeah I'm now a missionary
Hopper's yeah I'm gonna send poppers now
now you don't want poppers dude that's
for kids hold on as an aesthetic
alternative to PC Pete do you um live in
bro it's good to me no it's
methylamine oh it's hydrochloride it's
similar to poppers I'm gonna say Kimmy
is all stone especially if a second
effectors anesthesia
okay it blocks pain signals yeah I did
feel good dude hey how is your fight I
did this I did this on a Thursday night
no [ __ ] given what do you think I'm
gonna do in Amsterdam
dude why not coming back right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]